think you know if i have my house in la
i'd love for you and true to stay there
for as long as you guys need to yeah you
heard that right
tristan thompson just told khloe
kardashian she can live in his la home
forever i'm really just enjoying my life
in a sneak peek at the upcoming season
of keeping up with the kardashians
the then exes and parents to
two-year-old daughter true
chat about coco's upcoming home
renovation
and it's pretty clear their chemistry
is still very much alive and well we
start the renovations
february which will be like around the
corner but
it's a lot you know you have to pick up
and move and then you're going to have
to
relocate i like to make sure something's
safe or true and comfortable and still
something close because i have to check
on this house
i have my house in la i'd love for you
and true to stay there
for as long as you guys need to and i'll
give you guys the keys and
you can go party on youtube whoever else
yeah he clarified that whoever else
means coco's bestie
not another guy whoever else yeah like
malik and stuff listen
no one's gonna get ideas now okay no
guys um
better be me or surpass okay that'd be
one of the guys that stepped on that
property
thanks tristan we got it
but all joking aside the cleveland-based
basketball pro's offer was
over the top generous that's really
really nice of you but then what happens
when you come back from the season
i'll come back from season i can find
somewhere to stay but you're not getting
an apartment so i can stay in your house
that's like
insane any casa su casa who knows can
just lived there forever
[Music]
it's not happening like i said
chemistry it's a beautiful thing to get
along
with each other and for your kids to see
that of course chloe and tristan split
in february 2019
after his cheating scandal with kylie
jenner's former bestie
jordan woods you know things happen and
of course i'm sorry and apologetic as
much as i can be
but they made sure to build a positive
co-parenting relationship for true
i think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style
we come from a family where we believe
in that and you share children with
people and that's how
it should be and love is love and now
the two are very much back on i love it
earlier this month a source told et that
the pair are
back together and things have been going
really well
i'm just super happy and content things
with chloe and tristan have been great
and the couple is taking this time in
quarantine to really reconnect
and enjoy one another we're gonna swing
you here hold this hand we're gonna
swing you
one two
three
[Music]